الى اوكرانيا الان حيث اكل الجيش
الاوكراني ان قوته تواصل تقدمها في جبهتي
الشرق وزبروجيا فيما جددت موسكو نفيها
لحدوث اي تغيير في المواقع على الجبهات
وحملت واشنطن مسؤوليه اي تداعيات
للاستخدام اليورانيوم المنظم في معارك
اوكرانيا ينضم الينا من زبروجيا الان
ليسكره ومن موسكو نور الدين دغير نبدا معك
الياس كرام وانت ترصد فيزا بروجيا طبيعه
القتال والتقدم الذي تتحدث عنه في هذه
الجبهه كييف
هذه المناطق التي قال الجيش الاوكراني
بانه
حقق فيها انجازا عسكريا كبيرا في الايام
الماضيه وانه يتحصن في المواقع التي وصل
عندها لكن عندما يقول الجيش الاوكراني
بانه يتحصل عند هذه المواقع التي وصل
اليها هذا يعني بان تحركه وتقدمه نحو
مواقع القوات الروسيه هو زحف ربما يكون
بطيئا للغايه ولا يعتبر بطبيعه الحال
هجوما بريا كاسحا رغم ان بعض المصادر
العسكريه الاوكرانيه التي نتحدث اليها
تشير الى ان هذه الجبهه سوف تشهد تطورات
دراماتيكيه ربما في قادم الايام ربما هذه
القيادات العسكريه الاوكرانيه تتحدث ربما
في قادم الايام عن هجوم ربما يكون اوسع
وعلى محاور عده لكن حتى هذه الساعه واضح
بان الهجوم بطيء للغايه يتقدم شديد وما
تحتله القوات الاوكرانيه هي بضعه
كيلومترات فقط لكن بالمجمل العام اذا ما
نظرنا الى الخارطه التفاعليه لتقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور ومجموعنا تم
استعادته من اراد اوكرانيه كانت يحتلها
الروس ويسيطرون عليها بالنيران نتحدث عن
اكثر من خمسه مئه كيلو متر مربع وفق
الخارطه التفاعليه لكن بنظره سريعه الى
هذه المناطق نرى بان ما حرره الجيش
الاوكراني من ايدي القوات الروسيه هي
مناطق متباعده وغير متصله جغرافيا البته
بمعنى بعض المناطق هنا وبعض المناطق هناك
على جبهه تمتد على مئات الكيلومترات وهذا
يعني ويؤكد على ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تقود في تلك المنطقه هجوما كاسحا لكن
التطلعات بان هذه الجبهه سوف تتواصل
يتواصل فيها القتال والهدف المقبل بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه هو الوصول الى بلده
توكماك هذه
البلده الاستراتيجيه الهامه التي يسيطر
عليها الروس وبعد ذلك الانتقال الى عقده
المواصلات
هذه البلده التي تعتبر ايضا خط امدادات
للقرن بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
الهجومي باتجاه ميلوتوغول القوات
الاوكرانيه حققت نجاحات جنوب بلده
روبوتينا والى الغرب في ريبوفيه وقامت
بدعم مواقعها وحفر خناقه في الاماكن التي
سيطرت عليها وفي اتجاه ضخمه شرقا تواصل
قواتنا هجومها جنوب المدينه وتحصن مواقعها
التي وصلت اليها القوات الروسيه هاجمت
مقاطعتي سومي واوديس بعده مسيرات من نوع
شاهد من شمال البلاد وجنوب شرقها 33 مسيره
اطلق معظمها نحو المنطقه الجنوبيه لاوديسا
وبجهود القوات الجويه والدفاع الجوي
اسقطنا خمسا وعشرين مسيره
شكرا
هذه النقطه نور تتحدث كيف عن التقدم لا
تعترف به موسكو وتؤكد على
استمرار التواجد وكذلك المعركه على حالها
في الجبهه ككل فيزا بروجيا والمنطقه لكن
الشغل الشاغل اليورانيوم المنظم والمواقف
الروسيه القويه تجاهها وصول او ادخال
اليورانيوم الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
نعم محمد الجانب العسكري الروسي حينما
يتحدث على انه لا توجد هناك تغييرات داخل
جبهه ربما يبني على مجموعه من المعطيات
العسكريه ودائره صراع اين تقع الان الحديث
عن الصراع على منطقه وكذلك في الرابوتينو
كان في وقت سابق السلطات اوكرانيا اعلنت
انها سيطرت على الرابطين وتبين بعد ذلك ان
الامر ليس كما اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه
بل القتال اغلب القوات الروسيه تتمركز في
رابوتينو وعلى اطراف المدينه توجد القوات
الاوكرانيه ولا تزال متمركزه هناك بمعنى
عملي بانه لم يحدث اي تغيير في هذه
المنطقه ومستوى النيران فعلا لا يزال
مرتفع هناك دفع بالمزيد من القوات من
الجانب الاوكراني وهناك رد من الجانب
الروسي ربما نشهد خلال اليومين الماضيين
وربما الايام المقبله هناك تغيير في
استراتيجيات روسيا بهذه المنطقه والانتقال
من حالات الصد الى حاله الهجوم ويمكن بناء
ذلك على الهجوم الصاروخي الذي تعرضت له
الحديث العسك هنا يقول بانما استهدف فيزا
بروجيا وهو ورشه للطائرات او مصنع
للطائرات الهليكوبتر تم استهدافه من قبل
القوات الروسيه بمعنى اخر ان الجانب
الروسي يريد ان يقول بان خططه لا تزال
امنه ليس هناك اي خرق لهذه الخطوط لهذه
الخطوط بل هناك تفكير ربما للذهاب ابعد
بمستويات لمنع اي
سيطره اوكرانيه او تقدم اوكراني على مستوى
هذه النزاعات ويذهب ابعد من ذلك ليقول بان
مساحات المعركه اذا ما حاولنا ان اتجه الى
وسط اوكرانيا الى وسط اوكرانيا والجبهه
الوسطيه الوسط ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
نتحدث عن باخمت كانت هناك محاولات قويه
للجيش الاوكراني باتجاه كلين شيفكا
نقطتين مهمتين من اجل التقدم الى باك مود
لكن الحديث الروسي هنا انه لحد الساعه
المرتعه المرتفعات في هذه المنطقه لا تزال
بهذا القوات الروسيه بل رده هذه الهجمات
ناهيكه عن القول الروسي العسكري بان منطقه
شمال والشمال الغ
من خلال التحرك من صفاته بهذه المناطق
يشكل نوعا ما من الحاله الهجوميه يشكل
الحاله الهجوميه للجيش الروسي كل هذه
المعطيات الميدانيه والعسكريه ربما قد
تقراها موسكو على انها رساله للجانب
الغربي خاصه في الرد على المواقف الاخيره
والدعم الامريكي الاخير بتسليم اوكرانيا
قذائف من اليورانيوم المنظم هذه القذائف
التي ترى روسيا بانها وان لم تكن وتعتبر
من اسلحه الدمار الشامل لكنها مدمره
للبيئه للوضع البشري والانسان في المنطقه
باعتبار ان استعمال هذه الاسلحه سيؤدي الى
اشعاعات نوويه
وتستدل بتجارب في كل من كوسوفو وفي غزلان
الحرب لوغوزلافيه وكذلك الحرب العراق
وبالتالي الولايات المتحده هنا تقول موسكو
ان الولايات المتحده تتحمل هذه المسؤوليه
والرساله
الروسيه من هذا الجانب على ان هذا الدعم
الذي تريد ان تقدمه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه للجانب الاوكراني هو في اتجاهين
الاتجاه الاول وهو ان الهجوم المضاد ربما
لم ياتي بالنتائج التي تتوقعها والنقطه
الثانيه هي ربما الذهاب بالحرب ابعد اكثر
من التفكير في الحل السياسي اما على مستوى
الجبات فيمكن القول بان الجانب الروسي لا
يزال يؤكد على انه لا يزال سيطر على
المواقع وهذا ما اعلنه المتحدث باسم قوه
دينيبر
[تصفيق]
في اتجاه زبروجيا صدت قواتنا وبدعم من
الطائرات اربعه هجمات للعدو في مناطق
فيربوف وروبوتينو وليس هناك اي تغييرات في
مواقع قواتنا في المنطقه وقد اسفرت
المواجهات عن مقتل قرابه اربعين جنديا
اوكرانيا وتدمير عدد من الاليات العسكريه
ومنصات مدفعيه امريكيه وبريطانيه الصنع
وفي اتجاه خيبسون واثراء جويه لقواتنا
وقصف مدفعين قضي على 65 جنديا اوكرانيا
وعدد من المركبات العسكريه
شكرا
لنور الدين غير من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لكما